there's a couple books and you play into
it and you locator port to anywhere
that's cool there's been a lot of
invention since I was a kid I think
smartphones really mention I would like
to see like this machine and you would
type in what kind of food you would like
and then they just automatically falls
out of the sky egg you can you guys on
about all the time egg you put another
egg you put in an oven there's a chicken
I think this inventions rubbish is much
better so I think would be really cool
is a dream recorder so when you wake up
the next day you can watch your dreams
again have you ever had a really cool
dream maybe not for everyone
[Music]
probably don't want to watch those back
again there I've got one conversation
grandma so you'd be on your date
whatever you're talking about ittle bit
oh yeah great chat not so good no that
chat meter right now you are come on
embrace I thought you're gonna say
robots come and pick up the litter but
now they arrest just eating my chocolate
boss throw the wrapper on the ground no
litter robot did you throw that did he
throw the rubbish in the bin good job
brother in traffic control will have a
very difficult time you find the
cauliflower scary yes you don't need to
fly be happy on the ground so you're
saying just as a normal car with sad
nerves it's very good you can tell how
long it's going to take but how come you
always lead